we've all heard about how the dinosaurs
died the story I'm going to tell you
happened over 200 million years before
the dinosaurs went extinct this story
starts at the very beginning when
dinosaurs were just getting their start
one of the biggest mysteries in
evolutionary biology is why dinosaurs
were so successful what led to their
global dominance for so many years when
people think about why dinosaurs were so
amazing they usually think about the
biggest or the smallest dinosaur or who
is the fastest or who had the most
feathers the most ridiculous armored
spikes or teeth but perhaps the answer
had to do with their internal anatomy a
secret weapon so to speak my colleagues
and I we think it was their lungs I am
both a paleontologist and a comparative
anatomist and I am interested in
understanding how the specialized
dinosaur lung helped them take over the
planet so we are going to jump back over
200 million years to the Triassic period
the environment was extremely harsh
there were no flowering plants so this
means that there was no grass so imagine
a landscape filled with all pine trees
and ferns at the same time there were
small lizards mammals insects and there
were also carnivorous and herbivorous
reptiles all competing for the same
resources critical to this story is that
oxygen levels have been estimated to
have been as low as 15 percent compared
to today's 21 percent so it would have
been crucial for dinosaurs to be able to
breathe in this low oxygen environment
to not only to survive but to thrive and
to diversify so how do we know what
dinosaur lungs were even like since all
that remains of a dinosaur generally is
its fossil
skeleton so the method that we use is
called extent phylogenetic bracketing
this is a fancy way of saying that we
study the anatomy specifically in this
case the lungs and skeleton of the
living descendants of dinosaurs on the
evolutionary tree so we would look at
the anatomy of birds who are the direct
descendants of dinosaurs and we'd look
at the anatomy of crocodilians who are
their closest living relatives and then
we would look at the anatomy of lizards
and turtles who we can think of like
their cousins and then we apply these
anatomical data to the fossil record and
then we can use that to reconstruct the
lungs of dinosaurs and in this specific
instance the skeleton of dinosaurs most
closely resembles that of modern birds
so because dinosaurs were competing with
early mammals during this time period
it's important to understand the basic
blueprint of the mammalian lung also to
reintroduce you to lungs in general we
will use my dog Mila of Troy the face
that launched a thousand treats as our
model so this story takes place inside
of a chest cavity so I want you to
visualize the ribcage of a dog think
about how the spine or vertebral column
is completely horizontal to the ground
this is how the Spiner of a febrile
column is going to be and all the
animals that we'll be talking about
whether they walked on two legs or four
legs now I want you to climb inside of
the imaginary rib cage and look up this
is our thoracic ceiling this is where
the top surface of the lungs comes into
direct contact with the ribs and
vertebrae this interface is where our
story takes place now I want you to
visualize the lungs of a dog on the
outside it's like a giant inflatable bag
we're all parts of the bag expand during
inhalation and contract during
exhalation inside of the bag there's a
series of branching tubes and these
tubes are called the bronchial tree
these tubes deliver the inhaled oxygen
to ultimately the alveolus they cross
over a thin membrane into the
bloodstream by diffusion now this part
is critical the entire mammalian lung is
mobile that means it's moving during the
entire respiratory process so that's in
membrane the blood gas barrier cannot be
too thin or it will break now remember
the blood gas barrier because we will be
returning to this so you still with me
because we're gonna start Birds and it
gets crazy so hold on to your butt's so
the bird is completely different from
the mammal and we are going to be using
birds as our model to reconstruct the
lungs of dinosaurs so in the bird air
passes through the lung but the lung
does not expand or contract the lung is
immobilized it has the texture of a
dense sponge and it's inflexible and
locked into place on the top and sides
by the ribcage and on the bottom by a
horizontal membrane it is then
unidirectionally ventilated by a series
of flexible bag like structures that
branch off of the bronchial tree beyond
the lung itself and these are called air
sacs now this entire extremely delicate
setup is locked into place by a series
of forked ribs all along the thoracic
ceiling also in many species of birds
extensions arise from the lung and the
air sacs they invade the skeletal
tissues usually the vertebrae sometimes
the ribs and they lock the respiratory
system into place and this is called
vertebral pneuma tissa t the four trips
and the vertebral Numa tissa T are two
clues that we can hunt for in the fossil
record because these two skeletal traits
would indicate that regions of the
respiratory system of dinosaurs are
immobilized this anchoring of the
respiratory system facilitated the
evolution of the thinning of the blood
gas barrier that syn membrane
over which oxygen was diffusing into the
blood stream the immobility permits this
because a thin barrier is a weak barrier
and the weak barrier would rupture if it
was actively being ventilated like a
mammalian lung so why do we care about
this why does this even matter oxygen
more easily diffuses across a thin
membrane and a thin membrane is one way
of enhancing respiration under low
oxygen conditions low oxygen conditions
like that of the Triassic period so if
dinosaurs did indeed have this type of
lung they'd be better equipped to
breathe than all other animals including
mammals so do you remember the extant
phylogenetic bracket method where we
take the anatomy of modern animals and
we apply that to the fossil record
so clue number one was the forked ribs
of modern birds well we find that and
pretty much the majority of dinosaurs so
that means that the top surface of the
lungs of dinosaurs would be locked into
place just like modern Birds
clue number two is vertebral pneuma
tissa T we find this in sauropod
dinosaurs and theropod dinosaurs which
is the group that contains predatory
dinosaurs and gave rise to modern birds
and while we don't find evidence of
fossilized lung tissue and dinosaurs
vertebral pneuma tissa T gives us
evidence of what the lung was doing
during the life of these animals lung
tissue or air sac tissue was invading
the vertebrae hollowing them out just
like a modern bird and locking regions
of the respiratory system into place
immobilizing them the four trips and the
vertebral pneuma tissa T together we're
creating an immobilized rigid frame
or that locked the respiratory system
into place that permitted the evolution
of that super thin super delicate blood
gas barrier that we see today in modern
Birds
evidence of the straight jacketed lung
and dinosaurs means that they had the
capability to evolve a lung that would
have been able to breathe under the
hypoxic or low oxygen atmosphere of the
Triassic period this rigid skeletal
setup and dinosaurs would have given
them a significant adaptive advantage
over other animals particularly mammals
whose flexible lung couldn't have
adapted to the hypoxic or low oxygen
atmosphere of the Triassic this Anatomy
may have been the secret weapon of
dinosaurs they gave them that advantage
over other animals and this gives us an
excellent launchpad to start testing
hypotheses of dinosauria and
diversification this is the story of the
dinosaurs beginning and it's just the
beginning of the story of our research
into this subject thank you
[Applause]